what's up guys welcome to behind the
scenes for wolfenstein liberation of
London so woven Stein is one of my
favorite games my all-time favorite
games Turner castle wolfenstein I played
that game a ton when I was a kid so I
hope you guys enjoy this behind scenes
let's do this
so today we are in an abandoned jail in
downtown Los Angeles we're starting
outside we're shooting with a water
truck and the cargo truck and it's
supposed to be raining but it's not
really raining which is why we have a
water truck we're gonna do a wet down to
make it look like it's actually raining
that the rain and post and then once
we're done shooting outside we're going
to come inside for the rest of the day
it's pretty gross in here which is good
for like production quality and
everything looks pretty awesome it's all
about this location it's so cool so
today we have a couple special effects
going on special effects are like
practical effects effects that actually
happen in the camera not on the computer
that's visual effects special effects we
got rain we have squids which are like
body hits or explosives packed under the
shirt that explode out to make you look
saggy a shot
we have dust hits that are shot from a
paintball and also circuits or spark
hits that are also shot from the
paintball as well hey I'm man Z and I
did the Wardrobe on this project the
costumes on this really fun because
it's like a blend of like historical and
like fantastic video game stuff so we
rented a bunch of German uniforms and
then we sort of spelled them up with
these creepy like Tesla packs and
custom-made vests and other fun
fantastical things like that my whole
body just shuts down
yeah not the mode back on Oh in the the
script our heroes take out all the
lights in the cell that they're being
held in and then they shoot up a bunch
of Nazis in pitch blackness we ended up
just taping a light to the front of the
gun and then ran the cable down the
gunman behind them and over to one of
our electricians named Tom who had a
hand squeezer or a hand dimmer and he
was basically bringing it up and
bringing it down very quickly so the
effective gave off was just the very hot
pops it cells infected look right in his
brain so my buddy Joe from synapse
effects helped out with kill zone and
Dead Island today he's here on smoke
ensign shoot and we're doing rain today
so he's got this like ten-foot rain bar
which is just a metal pole with a rain
post at the end and it covers about a
10-foot area and we have to kind of
punch in because we only have 10 feet
but it looks so good it's legit we can't
get any wise we'll just add the rain and
post for the lights but yeah he's just
going around with this like metal metal
hose and
I guess just making it rain so shooting
rain was really cool I've always wanted
to do it it was kind of challenging
though because it got everywhere I got
all over the camera got all over the
cabinet of the truck but I think it
really worked out he makes your film
look a lot more atmospheric same for fog
too
you can't show wind but you can show fog
blowing past your actors Clint gets
ribbed for his pleasure on his body hits
just for you Clint specialized so squibs
are awesome they give you a nice wet
look that you can't recreate and post
now the guys that synapse effects are
really quick so they've rigged it up a
bunch of these things and if you look
closely you can see where the costume is
scored so when I give the cue they hit
the wireless trigger which blows up the
squibs what would you do if I just like
don't don't do that what would you do
things yeah last time they did that I
detected the Jake Watson over a corridor
digital puts us up with his German
Shepherd
his name's Rocky and he's the best dog
ever dude his German Shepherd man the
Germans had German shepherds and Rocky
is a very well trained dog it's funny
because Rocky's super chill
he gives fist bumps and everything but
as soon as you put him next to a Nazi
and behind a barbed wire fence have them
start barking you get that nice menacing
look
and it's a woman's with your we did a
casting session and had a casting
director and the casting director was
like hey since these guys don't know
each other
you should have everyone play an airsoft
game together so like that's a fantastic
idea so that's exactly what we did we
went to TAC City North to play some bb's
did you have you ever played airsoft
before I have not
hey man I kind of hurt the day before
the first day of shooting we pranked my
roommate max who is the first lady like
at nine o'clock I come home by the way
we have 6 6 a.m. call time I may have
been in situations got different way I
can may have been arrested for matching
you'll see the video see what I mean
baby
this so on this one we use the
combination of airsoft guns where we
just painted the tip black and prop guns
a buddy chi built the huge gigantic
minigun that's actually from the game
and my buddy deed built the other two
assault rifles that are also from the
game this is a message for all of you
know like Stallone with us all those
guys man damn I don't need to do a split
I think people add a split
come on what are you silly have you seen
this I spit in your eyes all of you and
Statham
he has no catchphrase I have thousands
of them guys thanks for watching the
behind-the-scenes thanks for watching
the short film I really appreciate it
you follow me on Twitter on Facebook
follow me on Instagram
see you guys next time
you